[Music]
what's
[Music]
yo fenner jordan what's up guys oh my
god oh my goodness are you okay yeah we
just wrapped punch for punch you know
that show we're doing netflix where i
learn how to be a stuntman and do action
scenes are you okay i'm never better
because i just did my first big stone i
got sent through a wall i need you guys
to use the magic visual effects to make
it look really really cool we'll take
care of the vfx yeah we have two days
and an unknown number of shots you guys
got this right because i would like all
this pain to be for something
[Music]
yo what's up what are you doing down
there
just working on the uh puncher punch
stranger thing cfx
okay
oh
do your thing
[Music]
the main components we're going to need
to deal with here are going to be roof
replacement with the wire stunt you're
not able to have an actual roof in place
luckily for me they actually shot with
some panels in there which is awesome
reference for what we're gonna do
essentially what i just need to do is
match the perspective and create a roof
within
this area here once those are in there
i'll probably have to create some sort
of a light source so i'll block
something out in the form of a light
fixture just a classic fluorescent
office drop ceiling kind of lighting the
final step will likely be a bit of wire
removal for where the actual wire
harness lives
the main thing that we're going to be
having to deal with in this shot is
replacing the roof here i actually went
in and manually tracked this thing it's
a flat surface it's not too hard to just
kind of corner pin our element into that
area i basically painted up a clean
plate version of our ceiling essentially
doing a digital map painting of this
ceiling here so as you can see this is
essentially the completed element the
biggest thing that i'm doing to help you
know motivate the lighting in the scene
because we have those heavy titan tubes
flashing over top i've gone in and i
found some elements of lights from a
drop ceiling rotored them out added in
some tubes in there and then those are
actually flickering and so it gives us a
really nice effect where we don't just
see this light going from blown out
white to like faded down we actually see
the bulb the source of the light within
that element we add those over the top
and we have our motivated source of
lighting in the shot when the actual
titan tubes are getting brighter our
lights get brighter as well it just
helps to you know tie in a little bit of
our practical set with our cg additions
here so from there we end up with our
final shot i think it turned out really
well and that's credit to everyone on
set that did an amazing job shooting
this thing
that's the first vfx shot for you no
awesome dealing let's throw it in then
here's the final shot
that's a whole ass new ceiling let me
see that hair how'd you get that hair
fenner yeah oh my god it's that davinci
resolve magic mask dude how'd you clean
up the shirt it was like a combination
of like painting up kind of a clean area
of the jacket that wasn't being pulled
and then just kind of manually tracking
and smart vectoring it back in our next
shot here is immediately following this
shot in the cut where nico is now
levitating in the air we'll essentially
have to figure out a way to clear this
area out and then again wire paint outs
all over the place here that's the
nature of doing wire work like this for
me totally worth it you're not doing a
cg digi double that often won't end up
looking as good and then there's no
shelf on the wall so for continuity
throughout the whole piece there is a
shelf with some board games living in
this area for this shot it wasn't in the
take and we see a little bit of a
rigging team here so we'll clean that up
as well
hey jordan
jordan was originally supposed to do
this shot but he's been awol for a
couple days so i'm actually breaking his
computer just to see where he's at and
looking at his project it looks like he
went in and actually modeled a really
awesome version of this shelf using a
bit of that multiply trick to add in
some of the practical lighting because
we have that flickering this is gonna
actually brighten up and darken down as
we go through the shot and then also
adding in our shadow with that we have a
pretty integrated shelf in our
environment from there clean plating
cleaning out wires we're able to add
niko back in using our ai generated roto
mat so we have a clean plate of our
background that's matching all the nice
flickering that they had on set with the
practical lighting from there it's
basically just lens distortion camera
shake it just kind of draws the eye a
little bit closer in to what we want to
see
number two it's ready for you cg shelf
sounds great thank you man how are we
doing on time
well that's hard to answer because the
thing is the video is already out i'm
still watching netflix but we still have
to finish our shots which is in the past
because we're three days before the
video
comes out does that make sense no okay
great sounds great um
let's drop that in
oh the final shot with a cg shelf so we
saw the hand and we saw a bit of the
ceiling was unfinished how did you solve
those problems so for those jordan
actually went in and just used the eye
transform node in nuke and basically is
able to warp up the tops of the frame
and the sides of the frame as well so
you're just taking them and going
hey that's a great example now i
understand so jordan
actually made a cg shell for this shot
so fully modeled the whole dang thing
you have a lot of questions for him
about the shelf but since he's not here
he can't really answer them so yeah
moving on from those two shots this one
looks a little bit different the reason
for that is this is a pickup shot where
nico actually sees the chess piece
rising up luckily this green screen is
really really great like you can see
it's very even there is a lot of fine
hair detail and it's out of focus hair
which can be difficult to key the main
thing that i'm going to be adding to
this shot is our chess piece so this
chess piece is going to levitate up and
nico will probably take notice of it
when it's floating right up above him
here that asset is going to need to be
good enough that it can hold up being
center of frame just kind of right there
in front of your face i'm going to use
polycam and i'm actually going to see if
i can get up close and personal with our
little chess piece and scan it gonna rig
this thing up to a single armature bone
and then bring it into the shot and just
see about kind of doing some animation
tests of having it floating in 0g this
is the plate we're going to be using and
we're going to be throwing it over top
of our clean plate because this key here
has really you know there's really fine
soft out of focus hair detail which is
usually a bit of a nightmare to deal
with so i'm doing a standard key with a
key light it doesn't work that great but
what i'm doing with that alpha is i'm
then blurring our background like so and
then instead of doing a key we're
basically transferring all of this value
into here based on our green channel so
it's basically saying like hey anything
green turn it to these values which is
this image here that's essentially a
one-click key once we have this all comp
together i basically went in added a
little bit of camera shake and a little
bit of flickering cue the next shot
jesus
feels like i'm in the future in the past
the present all at once yeah do you have
those shots for me no
no it doesn't matter if the video's
already out and they're already watching
this no no fenner if they're watching
this and the cameras are on us right now
that means the video is live and the
only way for it to be live is if we do
all the shots if we don't time will fold
in on itself and sort of crumble around
us and dissolve like the back to the
future folks does that make sense to you
no none of it makes any sense i finished
that shot anyways you do have the shot
yeah okay drop it in i'm dropping it in
this is the after this is a vfx shot but
why how is it a vfx job oh chess piece
we have a chess piece you see that's a
cg chess piece right there matt is there
anything else no it's just a chess piece
that's actually a deep fake of nico
that's actually ren's head oh
so we had to shoot this
on a green screen
and it
looks flawless if you go side by side
here like the level to which it's green
that's like stock footage level we
should sell this one
so with natalie's help we got through
all these screen brands and i've got a
couple more shots to get through myself
and then we're done this thing pretty
cool we were actually able to do it even
without jordan
oh hey
it's not surprising to me now i have
another shot for you oh okay i didn't
expect another one it's got wire paint
outs it's got niko getting a concussion
dust there's electricity there's
stranger things goodness stranger thanks
goodness it's really awesome sounds like
the shot everyone has been waiting for
let's drop it in okay here we go you
ready hold my hand
you think we're gonna show you this shot
no it's on punch for punch go watch it
on netflix's youtube channel still
watching netflix there's gonna be some
other awesome episodes we're gonna be
doing the witcher day shift and cobra
kai so make sure you go over to still
watching netflix and check them all out
wait
wasn't jordan supposed to be part of
this like outro where's jordan he's on
vacation isn't he or
oh yeah i think he's on vacation well
either way go check out the stranger
things episode it's live right now i'm
still watching netflix punch full punch
guys
matt
jonah
fenner
hello
[Music]